il s'y préparaient depuis longtemps avec
cette grève générale les grands
syndicats de la france espérait que ce
qu'ils ont baptisé le jeudi noir
marquerait le début d'un grand mouvement
social travailleurs des transports de
l'éducation de la santé
ils ont été nombreux de partout au pays
à répondre présent huit cent mille selon
les forces de l'ordre
1 million 400 mille rétorque que les
syndicats dans la mire de ses syndicats
un projet de réforme des retraites
annoncée par le président macron une
réforme juste et nécessaire selon le
gouvernement une réforme qui va
appauvrir les retraités surtout les
femmes répondent les manifestants ça va
pénaliser
quasiment tout le monde et en
particulier les femmes parce que du coup
comme on cotise différemment bas les
femmes qui ont pris des congés maternité
ce scan salles seront pénalisés c'est la
retraite n'est pas que revenait dans bon
nombre de conversations aujourd'hui la
retraite a permis de cristalliser les
choses mais en fait autour de ça il ya
plein de gens qui en ont ras-le-bol donc
on pense que ça va durer plus longtemps
parce qu'il ya tellement de choses qui
se sont accumulés que s'il ne gère que
les retraites
à mon avis pour 6000 policiers y étaient
préparés et présents le long du parcours
prévu de la manifestation des
débordements pas tardé
au delà des syndicats un rassemblement
dont les récriminations allait bien
au-delà des retraites gilet jaune par
schiste étudiants black blocks
leur colère a fait basculer de fil des
événements ce jeudi noir devait être une
tournée pour que les grands syndicats
puissent se faire entendre d'une seule
et même voix mais leur prix de colère
est étouffé par les débordements leur
grande marche fait du surplace
ce n'est qu'à la nuit tombée que le
cortège des regroupements syndicaux
s'est finalement mis en branle une fois
les casseurs c'est plus loin alexandre
cheminots a attendu plus de trois heures
avec ses compagnons pour lui c'est
l'état qui est responsable des
débordements
et justement c'est ce qu'ils veulent les
temps chez nous montrer qu'on est des
casseurs alors que tu es pauvre est le
président macro qui cherche jusqu'ici
sans succès à rassurer doit présenter
les détails de sa réforme des retraites
aux tentes incomprise que rejeter en
milieu de semaine prochaine
de quoi nourrir encore un moment la
détermination des manifestants
ici marie-eve bédard radio canada
[Musique]